which is risky what's going on Bobcat oh
good morning I'm what is going on they
were telling me now I said I'm happy
that Bob is coming in they like you got
a call on Bobcat which do you prefer
I like Bobcat but Bob's flying okay see
I tried to tell you Jim he does first
pond caddy
it says on the show well look if I
suddenly wanted to be known as Bob it'd
be like when you know like Ricky
Schroder yeah who else did that when
they changed their name in adulthood to
a shorter name sighs Rick Schroder Rick
Schroder why there I think there have
been other people Rick Schroder is the
one that I feel like everybody points
out which I feel like is kind of the
opposite of what you intend to happen
right all it does is put more attention
more yeah you used to be Ricky Schroder
oh it was Prince now you had we were
talked about we watched your first
Letterman before just we were watching
his name end up before the show do you
like watching yourself old stuff you so
I can't watch Mike and especially by the
nature like I did see a little bit of
that clip recently and I'm truly there's
I'm not saying anything
yeah you sometimes why it's just like
yeah so I know what I was doing but it's
still kind of embarrassing I can't watch
old stuff it's shiny in a weird way it's
an exposing humiliating field there are
guys who go yeah
yes they're autistic anyone watch
themselves we're just like I just did
Kimmel and the thing is is now it's like
you do the show and that's not the thing
it's the clip that they make out of that
appearance right right and I told a
story that Jimmy didn't know was years
ago I knew years he had a brownie and
fell asleep probably before 10:00 and
we're all at his house for the New
Year's Eve party and Jimmy's just asleep
it was just weird you know you know hey
all right so so I went and I recently I
had moved and I found an Instamatic
camera and I had it developed and there
just three pictures from that party and
then everything else is blank and what I
remembered was is once he fell asleep I
went and t-bag everything in his kitchen
and did you get every egg that's the
story they're running right now they're
plugging in the news you know that's
their meeting but you know you don't
tell the guy before you go on you don't
tell the segment yes I'm gonna tell a
story about Jimmy's like what else you
got how do you go from because you were
pretty notorious for a while for your
Late Show appearances yeah set in Jay
Leno's chairs on fire and trashing my
show way worse and I had in my mind
again you know I don't watch old clips
those and I was on a show and my friend
played it and I was like wow that was
really violent I mean when you're doing
the Arsenio thing yeah Garcia was like
if you I watch the clip last night
Arsenio is that physically holding you
back and not like you know we're friends
way in yeah so yeah so they were he got
fired because well he got fired
basically because they put the chubby
chaser on in front of him behold
Farrakhan with they spit us out because
he had Farrakhan on that was why they
eventually do you think they had
anything to do with it oh that's it I
think it was because the the deal the
syndication deal was you had to put
Chevy in front of him and so it just his
ratings dropped off oh yeah it was you
know I mean it that ratings juggernaut
Chevy Chase Chevy's really hard you know
he's known for being on the set of
community called Donald Glover the
n-word oh my god really yeah
hindsight you know being what it is
probably not the right guy to make an
enemy out of based on Chevy so yeah our
city oh he's got dumped by Paramount and
I spray-painted Paramount sucks on the
backdrop and then I spray-painted
Paramount sucks on the backdrop of the
set and then I threw the the cushions of
the couch into the audience and then I
put my Doc Martins I smashed this $3,000
monitor I see yeah you'd like tipping
over this and then I smashed the back of
it and Wow
and then and then he's wrestling me but
he does get me like in kind of a hold
but then just as we're going to
commercial he goes look good I mean at
one point they get a like a legit and
you could tell it's not a prop security
guard it's a real security guard
real security guards on stage and five
guys just sitting there like trying to
steal this walkie-talkie goes like this
he goes he's not gonna do [ __ ] we're on
video that was the beauty of just a good
ride he's taking it to the next level
it's like now I just I'm gonna go out
there I kind of would a little bit
premeditate like you know you can't be
have a can of spray paint just appear so
that's why I got the arson charge on
Arsenio
no no Atlanta I got arson because I was
premeditated I brought like yeah I know
you brought like you literally just got
up off the chair and you set it on fire
well what also I had lighter fluid in my
pants so I opened it up and while I'm
doing panel and I'm with my ass I'm
soaking the chair that's multitasking no
one ever talks about that so oh so
you're doing it while you're sitting in
it lighter fluid on your pants till I
open it up and I'm squirting it out
yeah that's a that's my because I had
the lighter ends up being how are you
not afraid of burning like just like
striking a match or lighting and catch
it on yourself yeah I didn't yeah I
thought about that now that's good to
use like one of those like cooking like
barbecue lighters like the long I see a
Troy if you the only clip that I found
really really hard to find oh if you
look at the opening of Larry Sanders
where they reference it you can see the
clip because they watch it it's like
three seconds yeah because NBC just
pulled all the clips are they deaf of me
setting the tonight but it was it was
you know so Jay was like you know you
know you know and like well it worked
I'm here and that's where Jay got mad
actually because I said that it worked
yeah you know he did get mad that you
lit his set on fire I think he was mad
about that too
yeah and he actually sat on it and did
the panel well because he was forcing me
he's like sit down are you saying here
yeah that's right he tried to like like
like squat so his feet were on the chair
and Jay was literally like grabbing it
by the ankles with the fitment now just
sit in it now
I did I had to go to court
Oh which was funny ish because my
attorney she meets me on the stairs and
I just think going and plead guilty and
Grassi know I guess so I am so yeah I go
and then I had to do these commercials
public safety announcements and and get
a gig out of it yeah I made dental that
year
it was like it's really bad
it's really embarrassing it was I had to
go and I'd never do the sides but I had
to go
hi I'm Bobcat Goldthwait you know I can
switch back and forth but if you sit
there and separate the man from the
character fire-safe later cuz the
Burbank Fire Marshal didn't like notes
yeah premise was like who comes to you
with that premise and says no you this
is what you have to do yeah it was it
was through the the Burbank Fire
Department it was their thing and they
had to accept it and yeah I was like you
know you give you just folded it in I
need it I need a 10 you giving me an 8
you know so the other court probably
stipulated that they have to sign off on
whatever the fire say oh yes yeah yeah
so you at one point your career that you
were directing for Kimmel right yeah I
directed Kimmel so three years so how do
you how do you go from being like
developing a reputation for destroying
yeah late-night shows to being like
would you like to hire me as the
director for that yeah I mean that was
all Kimmel also ABC you know they never
mentioned that fire the other one you
know like black ops like Delta hiring
Isis yeah Kimmel you know I directed a
lot of segments and stuff on the man
show and Jimmy wanted me to direct that
show and and and I went in and looked
and he said what do you think I said
well it's I think I can make it a little
funnier but I it's like landing a plane
in Chinese you know it's so they can't
drive yeah and I was directing on when
it was live live Wow
while he was going out live for how long
did he do that it started live and then
and then there was a it just kept going
like it was like a seven second delay in
a 14 second then it was then it was just
different but I mean I've told this
story before was the true story was I'm
not even being cute oh yeah the band
everyone say you know everyone hates is
yeah okay when they were on they might
be nice guys but their manager came into
the booth and he's like who's the
director I go I am and he's like don't
shoot Chad profile only shoot him
straight on I'm like who's Chad he's
like our lead singer I got why can't I
shoot him from the side they go cuz he
has a big nose and I was like okay I
won't shoot Chad profile and the
cameramen are listening to the
conversation and their [ __ ] because he
could hear me talking to the director I
wouldn't shoot it that way so so second
song the and Kimmel the second song the
show goes out the air and so during that
I said to the assistant director I go
tell me when I have 10 seconds left she
goes okay so so so they're doing their
something she goes 10 seconds and I go
shoot the nose crews now and the headset
going hey man what are we gonna do now
and I go
getting in my car so when you're gonna
make a decision like that you run that
by Kimmel was just like no I trust you
yeah I just would do that kind of stuff
and that was the kind of thing Jim and I
and I had going you know where you know
sometimes stuff would pan out sometimes
but I love that yeah later on here laugh
really hard that's amazing and you you
got rid of two we talked to you get rid
of the character that you were doing in
zany you're on stage yeah I remember
what what happened I was I went back on
the road after doing Kimmel and I
thought I hated stand-up but I you know
but I didn't you know I thought it was
like I hated being on the road and and I
mean it doesn't even exist that but you
know 10 15 years ago it was doing all
the wacky morning shows you know it was
brutal
you know paintin teabag and yeah man you
know and yeah but it turned out I just
hated doing this character and it wasn't
even hate it was just that the yeah so I
I made a decision that I can't go on
there I gotta be gotta be no but I have
to go on and be myself and was it worse
doing them the morning shows and stuff
because you had to do the character for
them 7 o'clock in the morning at the
gear up yeah it's just it's just you
know I'm sure you do this to like you
come in and you're like hi and they're
like they're worried that you're not
going to be on an hour yeah it was it
really is exhausting when they're going
from your Wikipedia but I don't expect
to get again a Jim Norton expert where
they like see you from Bayonne where the
[ __ ] you want me to go with that it's a
great five minutes of fail and no one
cares so it's hard to get to be in
character yeah yeah yeah so so I stopped
doing it and then but at the same time I
was directing you know I did a lot of
directing folks aren't aware of like I
worked on Chappelle's Show I worked on
you know I just did a lot of stuff
behind the scenes and then I made laws
that Kimmel I I shot this movie for 20
grand with a crew from Craigslist that
was it got into Sundance and it was
which movie was it it's it's called
sleeping dogs lie it's called stay it's
a rom-com with a tiny bit of bestiality
in it yeah my 40 minutes so when I got
the call I really thought it was Jimmy's
you know his cousin sale cause sales the
king of messing with people but it was
really Sundance I was like hey Trevor
Krauss from Sundance and your movie got
in I go okay Trevor can I call you back
[Laughter]
so you're just one of those like
eccentric paranoid weirdos like I'm
gonna call you Sal is like you know Sal
if you're eating pizza or boxing you
know he's got a knock at it I was
watching the Jimmy Excel walked across
the set and you just see Jimmy cover his
nuts
just because Sal's gonna hit you it's
like Pavlovian and like Sal yeah there's
no one who's just you know there was a
producer on the show here just take the
guy's phone and put in a glass of water
like have to he cannot do that just
laying this Jeff rasa prank when he did
call Jeff Ross and told him he won
Dancing with the Stars yeah this is the
most unprofessional places my two weeks
notice
well can't it's like a weird
he cannot I have a respect for people
that will prank with things that you
can't take back like you know I mean
like the that I quit emails or putting
your phone in water it's like well now
my phone is ruined my joke
sometimes like we would team up on
things there was a bit that would be a
celebrity was in a box on on the
Hollywood Boulevard and and then people
come up and ask three questions and to
try to guess who's in the box and in the
and I don't know I was like sailing not
into this and he's like yeah they make
sail grab the people off the street and
I go let's try to kill it and so it's so
he's got a new contestant and this is
one we're alive and and Jimmy goes who
do you have with you and he goes oh it's
Barry Williams was like I had I put a
bunch of footage during the monologue
just me sitting in the audience eating a
sandwich like after a joke if it didn't
land I just cut to this pre-tape of me
eating looking at but then during the
commercial break I used to wear like
skirts and kilts or I just dressed like
I'm not just so I wouldn't take myself
serious you know uh-huh like if you know
if you're innocent brer oh and you're
yelling at people you are a douche I
mean who's wearing the Pope's mitre did
it feel good to wear a skirt I mean
Edward yeah that's comfortable oh it's
really comfortable so in the break I
come running down thinking about a gym
but it sounds amazing it's very freeing
it's really people wanted their brains
though you got a kilt mango plaid skirt
some fat Catholic girl's skirt is lame
Brian actually so during the commercial
I run down and and I know and I just I
just I just put my junk on his desk and
lift up my skirt and I go Jimmy Jimmy
Jimmy look so go what do you think this
look normal and then I run back into the
booth and it's like three two just
staring blankly and we're bad
see this is why you shouldn't have women
in a writers room but sales tenacious
but I think the the most elaborate prank
I did when I was on Kimmel was with a
Super Dave Bob you know yeah so he he
came on the show I never told this story
publicly he he could be a bit of a
curmudgeon I like him a lot but he's so
I was like who was on the show you can't
remember who's even on cuz it's such a
grind it's like this I'm sure you leave
like who do we have on show so Andy Dick
was on the night before so I had them
buy a TV and gift wrap it and I have two
unwrapped it and I put a card it's a
dear Andy you know killed it again love
and I gonna put this in Dave's dressing
so wound up who the [ __ ] is Andy who was
Andy that was on the show last night
that got a team name one funny thing
Andy Dick is everything like he's really
mad okay I go take put him out get him
out of that dressing room when there was
this tiny dressing room that had been a
closet that we had put it and there's
too many guests I go put him in the
closet dressing room and then he's on
the phone yelling to his wife knock on
the door and it was just a little tiny
box it was a Jimmy Kimmel Live baseball
cap and I said dear guests thanks for
being on you got to talk about the
biggest prank of all time Windy City
have you seen that I know it's one of
the funniest movies I've seen parts of
ever seen any time
yes I'm YouTube the the controversial
director's cut yeah that was I can't
yeah I directed it I can't take credit
because it was a some of a lot of
people's work in engineering I mean I
I'm you know by the time we made Windy
City he you know mourned
I've been doing that for you know 11
years yeah
basically they pranked this guy scary
Perry yeah and they made a movie about
the prank he thinks he's at a real movie
but the whole movies is just a prank
actually starring in a Hollywood film
I'm a lot like Robert DeNiro my looks my
yeah so the punchline is just this thing
comes out and it's just kind of exposing
that this guy than that it's you have to
see it it's got levels it's late it's
like yeah so Perry brought a condom to
the set for the love scene and then I
you know cut and I bring in a stunt guy
I will I will I was watching the first
episode of the new show of misfits and
monsters monsters which Seth Green when
I first heard about it I was like this
is as big as like black mirror is on
Netflix I was like man to do a an
anthology show I'm like that's ballsy
but I watched the first episode and I
loved oh thanks man and I'm sure I'm not
the first person that's asked this but
is the so the premise of the first
episode and you know an anthology show
it's like it's its genre goes through
different genres and different topics
every time but the idea is it's a
voiceover guy in the cartoon character
that he voices is haunting him and
following him and yeah you know Bubba
the bear was like Cape Fear and Roger
Rabbit right combined where that's like
it's like why you got make me sound
stupid that's something funny for kids
that laugh at a stutter that's that you
know that's a tradition you know Porky
Pig Donald Duck Hugh Grant well he's
gonna send him straight to hell he hates
the bub of the bear hates the guy who
does his voice he tries to kill him it's
great it's violent and very fine I
didn't know that it was I thought it was
an episodic thing like I had no idea
that it was only one story okay yeah
yeah so which is something that happens
on the coaly [ __ ] that's the first
episode in the series doing 20 minutes
in that's where they're going
our protagonist can't talk anymore so
but what I was gonna ask is it like
based on you and your well I thought it
was a story I thought it was a little
bit based on my friend Tom Canty who
I've known since I was six who's the
voice of Spongebob and stuff but then I
realized I didn't realize it my daughter
pointed out she's my costume designer
she's like this is about you dummy
that's what I kind of thought she was
like you really think this is not about
you it's about this character that you
can't escape oh yeah but I think I'm
actually the bear because at the end the
Bears got set by the neck and he goes I
was a bear goddammit and you made me in
some kind of joke and I'm like I'm a it
could be I was a comedian and you made
me but yeah they're all different you
know the one that airs tonight on truTV
at 10 o'clock is it's David Koechner
plays a used car salesman in the 70s
like a guy who does his own commercials
one of those kind of guys and they run
him for president and he's like this
campaign manager says is there anything
we should know about you I cheated on my
first wife well that's what first before
anything else oh yeah I'm a werewolf
anything else yeah ate a toddler one no
one's perfect so so they run this guy as
a political candidate and and there's a
cub reporter trying to break the story
and I don't want to ruin it for people
but yeah yeah and justing idea for sure
isn't it great truth I'm not being
married with it like you could just
switch story to story you're not gonna
get bored of characters yeah I think I
hope that that's what it's just you
wonder if folks are gonna turn I don't I
hope people like the show and keep going
because the nature of anthology shows
this shows that you're gonna watch
channel I didn't like that one you're
like I love black mirror but some
episodes don't click for me as much sure
some of the other one if the order
doesn't matter you can just go back and
watch him it does you don't have to know
watch season one to enjoy season two
yeah yeah definitely and then there
they're all over the place I mean
there's like ones like I wanted to do a
Jerry Lewis
and it's set in the basically it said in
Dealey Plaza it's did the episode is
airing tonight did it really just start
with like watching you know one of these
hysterical people on the news going on
this monster is our president and you go
like what if what if was a monster yeah
it was that was the germ of it it's it's
funny it's like some of the stuff I get
on I'm there was like you know and I did
a movie called god Bless America and in
a fantasy scene thanks we shot a baby
but there's a scene in the that Jerry
Lewis episode one with Josh Batum where
I was like I think someone should
probably tell me no he gets it's a
time-travelling episode he gets to see
the alternate reality truman gets
assassinated and we had a Nazi occupied
us and he's watching these clips and and
there's this there's a kid you know it's
just like well there's full house h aus
and then there's like the ssme little
tiny boys before in lederhosen blonde
haired kids
he got shy and the whole crew did you
ever see an again some a few people have
seen the Jerry Lewis movie where he
plays did not see I've seen no no it's
really hard to see yeah because he he
owned it and I think there's like even
you can't see it complete
like there's a real missing mmm but no
I've never seen that somebody who saw
that nobody I don't know somebody did
see it recently I've seen the whole
thing there was footage that came out of
it no but somebody saw it I don't
remember who it was somebody no the kind
who was in spinal Harry Shearer Harry
Shearer yeah yeah uh-huh
Harry Shearer yeah I think watched it
yeah I don't know the day the clown
cried it's a comic at a concentration
yes I guess a Jewish clown who books
that do you find it easier like can you
watch stuff that you write and direct
more so than you can watch stuff that
you perform in yeah yeah when I'm in it
it's hard to watch but this stuff I
write and direct you know the obviously
the process you end up watching it over
and over and last night we had a
screening it's you know unlike the these
small movies I make I see those movies
when they're in festivals and their
screenings so the TV show it's been fun
we've had a couple screenings and to sit
there with a live audience to see if
things are playing you know when you do
a movie like god Bless America like Bob
is a bear I showed that last week at a
premiere and when there was gasps and
stuff yeah I I hoped and I thought that
the people would find the show funny but
when there's people gasping I I was I
was happy and and surprised because I'm
like seth's okay he's right here he's
right but it was cool to see people flip
out yeah you did interesting take two
because you know when you know about our
you were close to Robin and you talked
about being angry at him which is it
people don't usually admit that when
somebody kills himself there's an also
an anger if you can't get mad or
whatever it is I have to say that that
only hit me just recently you know
because I went through a bunch of
different stuff when he passed away and
but just just lately you know it is like
we were friends for 31 years and
sometimes he'd be gone for a long time
on location or something we didn't in
you know and I'm really
I'm not gonna talk now I'm not gonna you
know I'm not gonna see him I'm not gonna
say I said yeah I guess yeah I got angry
but it's weird you know there's there's
you know and I'm not I did I not out of
protest but I'm just not involved in the
book and this documentary and other
things just just because I think we were
really close because I kept a lot of our
personal conversations super private so
so that's it just seems weird I don't
know and I certainly would be hard to
watch the movie they just didn't but but
you know I have openly say stuff
sometimes you know I mean the thing is
is you had this thing Lewy body dementia
which was misdiagnosed as Parkinson's so
his brain was totally attacking him and
he was getting misinformation so he's
going to like you know handful of
doctors he's he's sober he's doing all
this stuff and he was just processing
reality really weird and in in I
honestly didn't have a friend that I was
in better contact with we talked in text
everyday or mostly you know especially
when he was ill but but he in my mind he
he did fight depression the whole time I
knew we knew each other any any wolves
winning you know I mean that's the thing
is like people go oh he was your friend
did he ever talk to you about suicide
and like we're comedians we talked about
suicide for 31 years
Thanks how would you do it so yeah we
went dark but but this was a different
thing that I you know and I miss my
friend so yeah lately I've been a little
mad at him is there is there a part of
you that like even though you don't want
to necessarily be involved in the
projects when the documentaries come out
and things like that the fact that
you're not involved that no you don't
want you don't need the credit for the
relationship I do yeah yeah it's just
you know I feel it was just like I said
like we weren't like
I mean we're really close we spent and
and and so I don't really in and even
that I mean we'd worked a couple times
on a public level and we would do things
like I was his date to the Oscars once
which is funny me sitting in the third
row the Oscars it was like a make-a-wish
kid just said that Wow holy cow I think
I'm gonna marry you yeah yeah you know I
I I always say that that I know who we
were really good friends because I spent
a fair amount of time bored with him so
right yeah yeah if you think about that
just hours just doing nothing and just
being real friends but you know but he
would play call of duty for hours on end
and I'm like hey man let's just do
something almost almost you know be and
if the thing which I liked was he was
playing other people and finally one day
I was like how old are these people
you're playing these I hadn't known 1213
so I love that there's like kids like
going the genie from Aladdin called me a
[ __ ] that's pretty fun that's
amazing especially because his voice is
so like yeah like I don't know how you
are you [ __ ] a little prick and did
you see Barry Crimmins before he passed
away
oh yeah I was there while he passed away
it's just I'm a lot of laughs ah yeah I
held Barry and yeah I was there with his
widow with Helen um yeah so through that
whole process I got to see him and talk
to him before he he he was in the state
that he was when he left but yeah so
yeah it was um
um I did call me lucky the documentary
on him and now I'm gonna do a narrative
film with Judd Apatow where Judd and I
writing the script and and I'm directing
and he's producing and we're doing a
story of Barry's life which is how I
originally wanted to do it with with
with Robin actually and Robin was the
one who said we're all getting old he
gave me some money to start the
documentary that's not called me luck he
got started Wow but um so Barry's just
just you know he's on his way out and
he's like I gotta talk to you and he
shoves me into the kitchen I think he's
gonna tell me to take care of his widow
or he's gonna tell me he loves me and
he's like I'm on Mark Ruffalo to play me
in the movie Chris Pine he's like who's
Chris Pine I go how do you know Mark
Ruffalo he goes I really like it when he
speaks at the anti-fracking
demonstration so yeah it was yeah I've
heard people talk about the that's an
honor to watch someone go away and I get
it now you know it was it was very
life-changing you know I've never done
it were you actually no dude you're like
positive you know it's about to happen
and yet what is the positive feel for me
it was to be able to see him not be in
pain anymore and well truly the way it
was was a his wife hadn't eaten and and
I and I kind of hadn't left so I was I
convinced her to get some food and and
Barry had been in a comatose for a while
at this point and I left and he woke up
and he looked at her and she said I love
you everyone loves you you can go and
then he passed away and then I get a
text come back here ASAP
so I wasn't in the room so I thought wow
that's pretty awesome because that's how
it was supposed to happen he was
supposed to spend that moment with her
third wheel hey what are you guys
talking about so it did kind of yeah I
wrestle with you know any kind of rhyme
or reason to this universe and it kind
of made me feel like maybe there is yeah
that's how I work that's the way it was
supposed to
because I some last year I didn't know
of course that well but we knew each
other casually and I summit the festival
and we talked and then all of a sudden I
didn't even know he was ill ya know I
just came down really fast right yeah
but then I come back with the sandwiches
and he's gone and and how and sobbing
and I just go what'd I miss
I'm saying I'm going wow you're saying
this like like it's coming I'm going for
it you know what Barry would like this
and Helen did a genuine triple take like
she was just like that's good but just
not such a big just keep it small and
then we were sobbing and sobbing and
laughing and I'm thinking these doctors
think we're the biggest ghouls in the
world you know but that's that's how you
have to deal with this kind of stuff I
mean right it's it sure yeah yeah I mean
that's and that's how he dealt with that
kind of stuff he was you know it's funny
he he brought a you know people were
like you know you gotta be respectful
and all this and and then I remember he
brought a fart machine to my dad's
funeral not during the service but like
he could tell having painful small talk
with somebody I don't know you know just
and I wasn't always funny no yeah I've
never never not find that funny no one's
ever gonna be object to a fart machine
and awake when you do when you do a
movie like god Bless America and it's
like a pretty biting social satire I
mean everybody watches that they kind of
walk away getting what it was and a lot
of people saw it I mean and then the
culture kind of just continues on yeah
you don't I mean yeah there anybody that
goes like wait but we
like it's really yeah I don't I don't
think I was gonna change anything but I
didn't think things would be amped up
into an insane crazier level then I kind
of was predicting in that movie yeah it
went way nuttier than I I really did
yeah now it's kind of cute yeah I
remember when things were like that yeah
it was it was it's strange to see and
then there's sometimes you know folks
will quote it and stuff which is strange
even to you know cuz because often when
I'm writing stuff I'm not I'm not
thinking the end product I just kind of
sit down and write you know I write a
lot I write a lot of scripts and and
constantly and I don't even know I don't
write them under the pretense that
they're gonna get made even I just get
them out of me just so how do you pick
what what you want to get me it's
usually oh what I want it's it's a bunch
of different things like sometimes I
think I'm gonna do this movie next and
then it just it's like a weird vibe like
it's like no it's not time for the gay
Billy Jack movie kicking morena yeah so
and when you would you make yourself
it's hard sometimes to sit down and
write like I get so distracted with not
so how do you for [ __ ] or one place you
go or are you good to just open your
laptop and only [ __ ] I'm gonna write
no I I go away I go into a hotel go out
of town and and the guilt of paying for
the room and you know and then I just
write for two days a week will you get
like it's usually it's usually like four
four or five days that you know
sometimes I can knock out a whole script
in a week but but it's just so there
just to get it out of you and and you
know cuz if I'm in Los Angeles or in New
York you know my friends are gonna go
hey let's go to a movie let's go goof
all right so is it have you always been
a person that like adjust your
atmosphere to make you do things because
you have to go to a hotel you know in
another town or something in that way
and and paying for the hotel is what
sits there and kills you into doing this
yeah I said when you were on Kimmel you
were wearing ridiculous outfit
so that you could make it so that you're
not gonna take yourself seriously yeah
but do you sit there and just figure out
how to adjust your at can you only come
with a gun pointed but yeah I guess I do
I do make you know my go-to place is you
know I woke up this morning and I was
just everything was horrible
and there's absolutely nothing horrible
it's just this weird thing like last
night start starting point and so
everything is always like all right well
I gotta do this so I thought yeah it's
just all these things that I have to
just to just fake normal your self out
of it like it's a chemical thing like
you wake up and all of a sudden it's
just like oh my [ __ ] god this is
horrible but sometimes you can pull
yourself out of it what do you do to
pull yourself out of it well I actually
stopped before I kick and stop and just
catch that that's what I'm doing you
know and and I really do if you know I
would cringe if I heard myself saying
this but you know sometimes it's a bit
of a meditation stuff just just because
my go-to places we're doomed
right and this is going to be horrible
and and all that kind of stuff and and
I'm always wrong you know predicting the
future is it on though is it on a
personal level for you or is it like the
world is doomed
the know for it's always first it's
about me right yeah the other day I have
a wonder the last episodes of the show
is animated and and I was looking at the
animation and I was talking to the
animator I was it was facetiming and and
I go point you guys made this really
funny you did a great job because well
everyone really likes working on this
they really you know I just volunteering
and everybody's been really kicking ass
and I go oh why is that cuz you're
amazing
yeah you know you know it it's
exhausting life is exhausting just to
not self-destruct and not be bitter and
all that kind of stuff
how long does something like that cuz
you can say you say that will recharge
you for a moment right when if somebody
says you're amazing that'll be like okay
no no I don't know about you when you
get done with the show and some ones do
you let any of that in very rarely
heroes if I know I had a good set like
there's times I did something recently I
was very distracted on stage I just was
feeling disconnected and depressed and I
thought it was okay and people had you
killed in my mind I'm like no I really
didn't yeah when you crush though and
you know it yeah I don't mind it cuz I
know it was a good show I feels legit
like it was a decent it feel better to
you like you are you like I'd like to
hear that sure I feel nice to hear when
you do it because the only validating
thing all day yeah you have to know it
you have to know you you have to know
you can write yeah yeah I guess it's
like it but I think we set the bar
really high like you said it had to be
you know you you knew that you were
present during that so yeah yeah yeah
it's weird it's really weird when you
switch characters be I don't know wrap
it with a show but did you did you do it
in the middle of a weekend or did you
how did you let yeah I started at
Thursday yeah and I think and I made the
decision honestly ten minutes before I
went and how would do they receive you
they were mad they were did you do it
all or no because I knew I had a whole
hour we annoyed people going like I'm at
stubbornly I am NOT going to do this but
I'm sure you guys know - it's the more
they I got it's not gonna happen right
yeah
and had it but how did you didn't it
affect your timing and certain
punchlines are contingent on a sound or
a facially danger yeah or even like oh
the punch line is that persona guys like
oh that bits dead
Thursday and said [ __ ] it this weekend
ticket sold yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was it was it was scary but I had to and
and lo and behold I actually do
sometimes enjoy doing stand-up again